[Music]  well here's another thing why  are we keeping our eggs in the fridge  chickens don't only in america chickens  don't keep their eggs in the fridge in  britain you don't need to no well you  don't know you don't need to in america  sure no you do why because the they're  looked  they're looked after in different ways  the chickens no the eggs whatever they  do eggs over here yeah before they go to  like ralphs or vaughn's or whatever  those are supermarkets in the united  states for people um before they go  there they do something to them all  right they they wave something over them  a light or something right ultraviolet  or something and after you do that to an  egg  you have to keep it in the fridge in  britain  sounds like you're making it up honestly  that sounds like you're making that i've  looked that up but i just scanned the  article  [Music]  all through the night you're shining  bright i'm your host  [Music]